if there's any young children watching
you should close your eyes
i'm being a really bad influence right
now
so when i search my google photos for
giraffe it'll show animals that are
not a giraffe look at this
it'll show the this uh zebra
uh this was actually in indonesia it was
like a in the car
safari and we the zebra would come up
and we'd feed it carrots
happy zebra let's
play another random sub
what why are my rooks being cuddled
and my knights are in the corner it was
actually kind of funny
i feel like the yeah the pieces are
lacking harmony
a little bit what is this
the knights have no legal moves
i also i don't have casting rights
can i justify this
let's start with c5
i mean probably the the best moves are
to move back and then fiancado and then
let's start with c5 though because i
want to bring the knight here
might even like play f5 and bring the
other knight here
yeah it's hard to play a staff or gambit
when my
knight starts in the corner
i'll try and make this work maybe i'll
play this and this
white's just playing like a version of
the open sicilian
um
yeah let's play f5 not
not holding back have some nice symmetry
going
if knight c3 i'll play knight f7 uh
it'll be a bit more asymmetrical
oh zach budai first time making into a
stream
yeah if you're new here say hi in the
chat
and hopefully people will be welcoming
i guess my king will just stay in the
center
and start with this move
oh a lot of people saying hi that's so
kind
rook is useful now on g7 targeting the
g-file
preventing the bishop from developing
the bishops still have no moves
so it might be worth
ooh so white wants us to
to be solid
i kind of want to gab it here
like b5
b5 so the pawn is supported by the
the knight in the rook i want to play v4
i also want to play rook b6
enabling this and and more stuff
have i ever played a game where i only
move the king
and not that i recall i mean most games
your
king can't really move the yorkie has no
moves in the starting position
i played games where i just try and make
pawn moves for as long as possible
can be a fun challenge
okay so hitting the pawn
or hitting um the knight with a pawn
opening the queen opening the bishop
i'm just trying to make my pieces happy
white was close to smother meeting white
needed two more moves queen e2
and knight f6 would have been really
tragic
but that didn't happen
and take with queen pretty sure this
pawn is uh
is just a goner white's still really
solid though like it's gonna take
going to take work to kind of break down
the king side
assuming castling is coming
okay what to do white's playing very
respectably
it's so tempting just to take on g3 that
pawn's pinned
i'll play f4
let's start with this move um
let's start with this move
this enables a few things i might want
to do this this
this or this and then eventually this
and then this
in combination with this
there's potential for all the black
pieces to be
attacking towards the king side like
bishops are already aimed at the king's
side nicely the rook and queen as well
i just want to get my other rook over
okay e5 just doesn't work here
oh it's so tempting to take the bishop
it's not good though but it looks fun
how bad is it
it's five plus three let's do it
oh no my queen
because that's so that's the one thing i
wanted was a g-file to be
open so i basically i sacked my queen
to open the g-file
and now the bishop's pinned so there's
some compensation and now i have this
move
[Music]
oh no my rook i can take it two
different ways
if there's any young children watching
you should close your eyes
i'm being a really bad influence right
now
a queen f4 rook d2 this is
all probably just objectively bad for
black but
it's one way of having fun
yeah so now i can take here
and all of a sudden okay what happened
so i lost a
queen in the rook i'm down
[Music]
i don't even know i'm down basically
a queen and rook for
knight bishop and pawn but i'm going to
win this bishop
and then someone's meeting so it's kind
of working out
smothered
what about this game i just need to get
my knight
opponent wants to
and do mean things to me too
yes mother made this game probably won't
be possible but this stream
i'll try and make it possible i could
win the queen back
but i'd still be down to exchanges so
i'll play
this move too wait this might just be
winning
this is only one check oh maybe it's two
checks
oh no i'm gonna get forked or i'll lose
a pawn
but my king will will survive yeah i'm
losing a bishop
also white can't stop me or
can't oh i can
oh no
[Music]
the king is running
wait this looks really fun to calculate
so i have bishop f2
king d2 bishop
the king's just gonna run to c1
i thought i was winning it takes more
work though
i could actually play
i should start with bishop f2
and probably bishop g3
so delivering check and now takes and
then i'll win the
oh there's some smother made possibility
again it's really difficult without um
i guess without having a queen to
sacrifice
yeah let's take the rook
i try and smother mate with my bishops
[Music]
okay so the the rook supports the bishop
take the rook here wait this might be
force mate
yeah i think this is horse mate king b2
only legal move
and i'll move back with the bishop so
these squares are all controlled
queen c2 is only they will move i'll
have some windmill
yeah i guess uh there are a few
different rookmates there
okay that was fun well thanks for the
game alex
morgenthau uh
i feel bad like with completely reckless
play
paying off there um
but i i will say when i played queen
dixon 4 i saw the
idea of rook d2 and it shouldn't be
good for for black
but it is tricky because as white like
you're
you're being attacked this way in this
way in this way
um yeah maybe the best move is knight
takes i'm not sure
yeah knight d2 or queen d2
but here like yeah white has to be kind
of precise to
stay alive
oh was i vicious and devious
yeah maybe that was slightly vicious and
devious but it was also youtube worthy
a lot of the youtube content for this
stream